good defensive guard [ __ ] handoffs  damages action to the air rejected by  right side it was in the weeds wait for  Emma he's got a teammate open Rodney  first in a Carmelo missed three it comes  off into the hands of Saturn ski has  been very active early on both ends to  market and into the lane second walk of  the night by Whiteside who reels it in  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  245 left first quarter will be white  rejected by a white side I got it for  four blocks tonight one with the horses  eaves  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  blocked by Whiteside  I've blocked rec will be white rejected  by what's up the Sun being a presence in  the paint  the other way  traffic at ball McNees coming with a lot  of heat Chicago the other way a minute  49 remaining market have passed up the  three to drive at thought Whiteside who  blocked the shot without foul  what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks  with bleacher report make sure that you  subscribe for some more video content